everyone is still talking about Gayle
Kings interview with our Kelly 24 hours
after that interview he found himself
behind bars again for not paying child
support now in part two of Gail's
interview she asked Kelly about his
three children and once again he became
very emotional what is your relationship
with your children Chicago authorities
say our Kelly won't be released from
jail
until he pays one hundred and sixty one
thousand dollars in back child support
he owes he was taken into custody
yesterday and is expected back in court
next Wednesday child support
[Music]
he's very broken in many ways but he's
also very strong CBS this morning's
Gayle King is winning praise for her
composure during the emotional interview
Robert Gayle spent 80 minutes
questioning our Kelly and asked him
about the stars who have publicly
criticized him and I said you know John
Legend has called you a serial rapist
Lady Gaga has apologized for working
with you he said you know listen they're
entitled to their own opinion and I
think he's disappointed that you know
people have turned their backs on him
after gales interview i Skyped with our
Kelley's former collaborator singer
Stephanie Sparkle Edwards never
introduced her to him
she was featured in the documentary
surviving r.kelly and claimed her niece
was the underage girl in an infamous
r.kelly sex video spark who you had a
chance to watch the interview what's
your big takeaway from it sad why just
sad to see the person that I once knew
just lose it the acting not a good
acting part so you believe he was acting
that he was putting on a show in part
robert is always putting on the show
trust me
now tomorrow night CBS news will
broadcast the Gayle King interview with
our Kelly it's a one-hour primetime
special
[Music]